and the grammy goes to beyonce
blue ivy and wizkid beyonce and jay-z's
little girl blue
ivy just won her first ever grammy
this makes me proud on sunday the
nine-year-old took home
grammy goals for best music video for
her and her famous mom's song
brown skin
[Music]
you for girl else singing beyonce's
co-director accepted the honor just
hours before the televised ceremony
thank you to beyonce for seeing me
in your vision for this important song
and for this moment
i collect this award award on behalf of
she and i
the big win makes blue the second
youngest musician to take home the
coveted
[Music]
blue is awards both in the vocals for
the song which
she wrote a verse for and in the music
video alongside her mom
the song was originally featured on the
soundtrack for disney's live action
2019 remake of the lion king which
beyonce curated
and the music video was made for queen
bee's 2020 disney plus film
black is king but this isn't blue's
first big honor
she already has a bet award soul train
music award
and naacp image award for the song
and of course her grandma tina knowles
lawson couldn't be prouder
oh my gosh she's amazing shortly after
her granddaughter nabbed her first
grammy
tina took to instagram sharing a snippet
of the music video alongside the caption
quote
congratulations to my beautiful talented
granddaughter for being one of the
youngest grammy winners for brown skin
girl
you go my blue blue so proud of you
i never tried you for anybody else
singing